翻訳: Hiroyuki Sugiura
校正: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
努力すれば夢は叶う
叶わない人は
努力が足りないだけ
以前は そう思っていました
でも 今の私は
努力すれば夢は叶う
とは言えません
夢は 叶う人もいれば
叶わない人もいるからです
そんな 私の考えを変えた
話をしたいと思います
皆さん『ショートトラック』という
競技は知ってますか
知っているっていう方
どれだけいますか？
おっ すごい！
ありがとうございます
ショートトラックは
１周100mほどの小さなリンクで
４人から８人くらいの
人数が一斉に滑り
タイムではなく
駆け引きを行って
着順を競う競技です
「氷上の競輪」とも
呼ばれています
（歓声）
前から３人目の
赤いユニフォームを着たのが私です
（歓声）
こんな感じで競技します
私は この競技を
小学生の頃から始め
中学に入ってからは 週３回
ここ浜松から愛知県まで
練習に通いました
全国大会
ワールドカップ
世界選手権に出場し
夢は—
オリンピックに出場することでした
そして2010年
バンクーバーオリンピック
日本代表に選ばれました
私の夢が 叶った瞬間です
夢にまで見た
オリンピック選手になりました
日本を出るまでは
オリンピック選手っていうだけで
周りからチヤホヤされ
自分ってすごいなって
思ってました
しかし 選手村に入ると
全員が オリンピック選手です
当たり前ですよね
その中ですごい選手は
メダリストでした
私の結果は７位
オリンピックは
出るだけじゃダメなんだ
メダルを取らなければ
バンクーバーで
メダルが取れなかった私は
新たな夢を
オリンピックのメダリストになること
としました
2014年 ソチオリンピック
メダル獲得を目指し挑んだ
ソチオリンピックでしたが
結果は５位
メダル獲得の夢は
叶えることができませんでした
悔しい気持ちもありましたが
私は現役を引退しました
実は私 このオリンピックで
引退するって決めてました
理由は二つあります
一つ目は 年齢です
次を目指せば私は31歳
今がピークと感じてました
もし このソチで
メダルが取れなかったら
もう次はないだろうな
このまま続けていても
伸びる可能性は低いだろうな
４年後 自分が活躍する
ビジョンが見えませんでした
二つ目は 女性として
早く結婚して 出産して
家庭を築きたい思いがありました
スケートのない普通の人生を
送ることへの憧れがありました
なので 私の予定では
メダルを獲得して
気持ちよく引退して
結婚して
幸せになろうって
思ってましたが
叶いませんでした
2014年3月
私は 一般社員として
仕事に復帰しました
入社９年目でしたが
毎日スケートだけの
日々を送っていたので
仕事は ほとんどできません
周りの上司や先輩
時には 後輩からも仕事を教わりました
そんな日々が続きました
スケートのない日々は新鮮でしたが
私が思っていたものとは
どこか違いました
時間が たくさんできて
好きな事して
楽しい日々が待ってる
そう思っていたのに
何か物足りない
寂しい気持ちが
込み上げていました
何をしても楽しくない
気づけば
心にぽっかり穴があき
そんな自分が
嫌いになってました
これまで 目標に向かって
限界をつくらず
走り続けてきたのに
今の私は 夢をあきらめ
自分の中に
限界をつくってしまった
家庭を持つことは30代でもできる
でも スケートは今しかできない
私は 再度
挑戦する決意をしました
これは 私のわがままです
わがままを承知で
スケート部の監督に
「もう一度スケートがやりたい
復帰させてください」
とお願いしました
しかし 断られてしまいました
監督からは
「スケートも会社もそんなに甘くない」
と言われました
それでも諦めきれず
私は 何度も監督のもとを訪れ
復帰したい思いを伝えました
「その気持ちが あと半年
続くようなら考えてみる」
それが監督の回答でした
私は この半年間で
自分自身 スケートと
しっかり向き合い
気持ちの再確認の意味を込めて
地元浜松のクラブのコーチや
大会役員など
スケートを 違う角度から見て
スケートが 心から好きなこと
夢を追う自信を取り戻しました
2015年4月
スケート部への復帰です
ただし条件がつきました
それは 仕事を１日こなし
勤務時間外で
トレーニングを行うこと
日本代表に入り
平昌オリンピックで
メダル獲得の可能性がある場合のみ
会社としてサポートする
との条件でした
過去の経歴など関係ありません
ゼロからのスタートです
スケートと仕事の両立
仕事面では 職制としての責任や
新たに役割が課せられ
時間外で行うインフォーマル活動や
残業の日々を過ごすようになりました
朝７時半から夕方６時頃まで働き
夜の７時から８時まで
ウエイトトレーニング
８時半から10時までスケート
家に帰るのは 11時でした
トレーニング計画を立てても
残業で遅くなった日は
氷にすら乗れません
時間のない日は 自宅でローラーを使用した
自転車トレーニングを行いました
スケート部に在籍していましたが
他の選手と一緒に
合宿に参加することはできなかったので
一人で長野へ行き
合宿を計画しました
練習相手もいない
タイムを計ってくれる人もいない
ビデオを撮ってくれる人もいない
そんな中で一人で滑りました
宿泊代や交通費
リンクの貸切代は
全て実費で支払い
この年の給料と有給は
全てスケートに費やしました
これまで国や会社のお金を使って
コーチ スタッフの方が
スケジューリングしてくれて
何もしなくても
練習場所があって
ご飯が出てきて
寝る所があって
休養時間があって
選手は ただ滑るだけでした
スケートをやることって
こんなに大変だったんだな
経験して初めて知りました
そんな日々を送っていたとき
私の耳にスケート関係者から
こんな声が聞こえてきました
「どうせ代表には戻れないよ
ピークは過ぎたよね」
すごく悔しかったです
確かにこの生活では
練習量も足りないし
代表復帰は 厳しいかもしれない
体の疲労や
精神的疲労もあり
心が 折れそうになりました
仕事がなければ
もっと練習できるのに
そんな思いもありました
そんな日々を送っていた時
職場のみんなが
私が 就業時間後に
トレーニングをしていることを気にかけ
私の仕事を
手伝ってくれるようになりました
「伊藤ちゃん—
後はやっといてあげるから
練習行っといで」
「伊藤ちゃんのスケートを
また応援できるのは嬉しいな
がんばろうな」
そんな職場の方の言葉に救われました
このとき私は
スケートも仕事も
100%で挑もうって決めました
仕事を一生懸命やることで
職場の雰囲気が良くなり
人間関係が深まること
私が 思っていた以上に
職場のみんなは
私のことを考えてくれていました
両立すると決めたのは自分
仕事を疎かにしてまで
スケートを復帰するのは違う
これまでスポーツは
「結果を出さなければいけない」
という意識が強いものでしたが
私の「結果を出さなければ」は
みんなのために
「結果を出したい」
に変わっていました
2016年1月
復帰戦の全日本選手権
みんなの思いを胸に滑りました
結果 私は２年間のブランクを乗り越え
総合優勝しました
そして 日本代表に復帰し
2018年
夢に向かって
３度目のオリンピックに出場しました
が 結果は６位
メダル獲得の夢は
叶えることができませんでした
今年の３月
私は２度目の引退をしました
引退は これで最後です
結局 私は復帰しても
夢を叶えることが
できませんでした
しかし 復帰したことで
私は 大切な仲間の存在を
知ることができました
諦めず努力し
夢を追い続けたことで
私は 本来の夢以上のものを
手にすることができました
私の中では
メダル以上の価値あるものを
得ることができたと感じています
夢に向かって努力したけど
叶わなかった
スポーツをしていると
どうしても「結果が全て」と言われ
実際にどんなに内容が良くても
負けたら意味がないと評価されます
でも 人生においては
夢を追う過程を
重視してもいいかと思います
目に見えるものだけが
結果とは限りません
目に見えないものであっても
一生の宝物になることもあります
私のように
（拍手）